bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous
parlais d'un tout nouveau smartphone le
umeji z2 prompt à smartphone chinois qui
me fait vraiment penser d'un côté à
l'iphone 10 d'un autre côté aux
nordistes
je trouve vraiment bien très intéressant
et justement je voulais vous en parler
on en parle maintenant
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez la
marque ou midi où il est j'y propose des
smartphones et les en sorte de le zz pro
et moi je vous parlais du zèle de proue
parce que je trouve vraiment intéressant
sans papiers quand on le regarde
du point de vue de la face avant il me
fait vraiment penser à l'iphone disent
vous avez une encoche qui est un peu
plus grande que celle du au nord si ce
qui ressemble vraiment aux dimensions de
celles de l'iphone disent vous avez un
design avec des bords légèrement incurvé
un écran qui est incurvé aussi sur le
banc une petite bordure noire en bas
mais bon rien de déco nord est bien
énorme
le dos me fait par contre pensez lui aux
nordistes vous avez un dock donne un
aspect de différentes couleurs ça ça me
fait vraiment penser au modèle du nord
et je trouve ça extrêmement jolie en
couleurs vous avez le twilight le
fantôme le noir et le twilight noir
c'est vraiment novateur ces différentes
teintes au dos du smartphone
et pour le coup c'est vraiment bien même
si au centre en eau vont trouver un
double module photo en dessous un
capteur d'empreintes digitales et clou
du spectacle le doubs est en verre pour
pouvoir permettre la recharge par
induction côté dimensions il mesure en
hauteur 153 4 mm une largeur de 74,4 et
une épaisseur de 8,3 mm tout ça pour un
poids de 165 grammes et je vous invite à
les découvrir je vous ai mis un lien en
bas
ici dans la description on retrouve un
écran de 6,2 pouces qui couvre 90% de la
face avant la résolution cdu 2246 par
1080 pixels cdu fhd plus avec un ratio
de 19 9 yens et une densité de pixels de
403 ppp niveau performances il un
processeur médiathèque
elio p60 détection face photo scène fin
tout ça on va en parler juste après il
est dispo en 6 giga de ram 128 go de
stockage que vous pouvez monter avec une
carte microsd en 256 giga la batterie
c'est une 3550 milliampères heures et
vous avez une dual fast charge 18 watts
par un câble et 15 watts en adduction
qu'en est il maintenant du côté photo
vidéo vous avez un double capteur
arrière et un double capteur avants 16
mégapixels 8 mégapixels de chaque côté
sauf que à l'arrière vous avez un
capteur samsung est à l'avant vous avez
un capteur sony à l'arrière on nous
promet des photos excellente ont fait le
luminosité à la vente un indice un petit
peu moins c'est que nous verture de f
2.0 et à l'arrière vous avez un goût
le flash led vous pourrez faire de la
vidéo en 4k en 1080p en 720p et tout ça
en 30 images par seconde comme ça dans
les iphone vous retrouver le mode
portrait avec différents modes de prise
de vues lumière naturelle lumière studio
et lumière stéréoscopique
côté os il tourne sous android stockent
8.1 vous avez fait cela qu'il s'agit
bien de file seul bloc c'est à dire la
reconnaissance de votre visage pas du
tout fayçal dit on n'est pas sur un scan
en trois dimensions de votre visage on
n'est pas non plus sur les mêmes normes
de sécurité mais pour déverrouiller
rapidement ça marche très bien
vous avez aussi capteur d'empreintes
digitales oddo situé sous le module
photo et pour la protection il est
équipé de gorilla glass 5 donc vraiment
solide il a du nfc pour les paiements
dématérialisés
vous pouvez insérer une double carte sim
intéressant pour tous les frontaliers de
ceux qui voyagent beaucoup pour tous
ceux qui ont besoin d'une double carte
sim en règle générale il a du bluetooth
4.0 une connectique usb type c est un
haut parleur mono on voit ce qu'ils
développent dans beaucoup de téléphones
et celui là fait pas exception c'est le
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle avec des processeurs
toujours plus puissants olive la photo
d'une vraie compréhension de votre
environnement et avoir une
reconnaissance de votre visage va y
avoir une reconnaissance de scène pour
optimiser votre photo tout ça semble
aller dans le bon sens pour pouvoir
aider les utilisateurs à faire toujours
meilleures photos pourquoi est-ce que ce
smartphone est intéressant déjà pour moi
le premier point c'est le design il a un
design qui est vraiment bien réussi à mi
chemin entre l'iphone 10 et le aux
nordistes
c'est vraiment un design actuel à
prendre pour les standards de square
trombe l'encoche le dos de différentes
tailles qui est vraiment sympa le grand
écran je trouve que de ce point de vue
là du point de vue purement esthétique
il est bien réussie le point numéro deux
c'est la fiche technique il a des
caractéristiques techniques qui sont
vraiment pas mal et qu'il devrait en
satisfaire plus d'un et le troisième
point surtout c'est le prix il est
vraiment pas cher les disponible en pré
commande jusqu'au 18 juin aux tarés de
249,99 dollars soit à peu près 2 112
euros hors taxes et si vous commandez
après 18 juin il sera au tarif de 299,99
dollars soit à peu près 2 154 euros hors
taxes vous avez donc un smartphone à
moins de 300 euros avec tous les codes
actuels la taille de l'écran
le design la performance les appareils
photos je tente doigt sur le papier
c'est un produit séduisant
à voir maintenant lors de phases de test
sans smartphone qui en précommande dès
aujourd'hui je vous invite à aller le
voir directement via le
dans la description pour les stocks des
coups d'oeil à les voir toutes les
photos toutes les vidéos et vous me
direz ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous le trouvez sexy est ce que ça
smartphones que vous pourriez posséder
est-ce que vous avez d'un point de vue
esthétique ce smartphone à mi chemin
entre d'un côté l'iphone 10 et de
l'autre côté le au nord 10 mark et moi
tout ça directement en bas dans la
description et dites moi comment vous
trouvez ce humide il gisait de prouesses
qu'il écoule pas cool
est ce que vous connaissez la ma est ce
que vous avez déjà eu des smartphones du
midi j et est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter par celui là vous ne
marquez tout ça d'ici là vous mettez des
jolies pouces vous vous abonnez vous
marquez tout ce que vous voulez
questions suggestions directement en bas
en commentaire je vais très bientôt
bisous bisous et à bientôt
[Musique]